What if this could change the world?
A burrito?
Yeah.
It can't.
It could.
You are so weird.
It could change how we plant things and grow things.
And improve the dirt where we grow those things.
It could save water by changing how we use it.
It can make us more responsible and sustainable.
It could change how we pick things, move things and transportation things.
What? That's not a thing.
Whatever.
It could make our farmers happier.
And they can make our animals happier.
Can trees be happier? Probably.
We could do things more locally,...
...so, everyone's happier.
More organic, more real.
Soil-helping, future-facing, less carbon-emitting and world-changing.
Are you still talking?